okay so um
no free lunch there's actually several
different flavors of the no free lunch
theorems
there's the ones that have to do with
induction
which can be viewed as a
formalization of david humes
informal idea
um and which have
lots of implications for machine
learning and so on and so forth then
there's also the versions that have to
do with um optimization and search
um
inference devices there's actually a
whole
bunch of impossibility results
um the
monotheism theorems and the days and
theorems and so on those are two of them
and they're up front
the noisy deductive reasoning
that's i wouldn't refer to that as
impossibility or no go theorems that's
very much work in progress um that's
probably
it's on the front most burner of all
those um uh separate projects
what is
what me and my collaborator david kinney
are doing there is instead
trying to understand what the
implications would be if we just
pursued the time-honored tradition now
in mathematics
of weakening one of its foundation
stones
let the edifice then crumble and relax
into a bit a somewhat different shape
than we had known before
and try to say some things about that
particular shape
so it's not so much a no-go theorem you
will not be able to
invoke it when you get one of your email
correspondence and say oh this violates
the blah blah
it's instead much more of a project that
in a certain sense is
even
undermining legitimacy of the others and
that it's saying
it's taken seriously